[Music]
guys uh thank you i love the shoes the
shoes are fantastic that camera have
zoom yeah yeah right here right here we
gotta turn it around fantastic just take
it off oh geez yeah yeah
can i just take it off emblem it's got
it's got an emblem on the side i can't
wait to buy these these are fantastic i
don't think you can buy them yeah
no i don't know yeah yeah i'm going to
get those no yeah yeah we can't let you
know you think only people that won the
world theories got to have them that's a
great point yeah yeah getting a ring too
now let's talk about the beards
fortunately you saved yours i understand
that uh a bunch of players have already
cut them off yep please don't fondle it
in front of me it's uh it's very strange
that you look at what
you're tasting food from three weeks ago
yeah
yes like when did i have curry
okay you guys replaced single-handedly
replaced the high-five with beard
tugging
and you tugged the beards yes uh we have
uh i think a clip a photo here
mr napoli tugging your beard and it
looks like he's really practically
hanging off of it is that true we're
still trying to find him yeah yeah
the ironic part about that right there
is both his thumbs are in my mouth like
i'm like a like a fish
we have done these tugs you know
numerous of times but
he had me like a like a bass or like a
salt means maybe he was checking for
decay he may have been
trying to help you out it was a pretty
important homer at the time pretty
important beard tug and all rules were
out on that little event yet i'm told
napoli fears you tugging his beard and
won't let you get near him is that true
we do a lot of the beer tugs yeah we got
rossi vic salty and uh i hit behind nap
a lot and he hits a lot of home runs
right and
i won't let you tug his beard he won't
he he's so you know what i felt it my
theory is it's fake again look at that
look at that boy
you know what i think it's a glue on i
think that's why he won't let you near
it it's fake and then he runs to the
dugout and everyone's doing like
pull-ups on his beard you know and i i
just can't even get a finger he's like
come on nap
come on now we're just trying to find
him you know yeah yeah